Shanti Devi at work she replaces truck
tires checks them for wear and tear and
fixes flats in a sari and bangles she's
an unusual figure in sanjay gandhi
transport nagar a huge trucking hub in
north delhi an estimated twenty thousand
trucks rolled by every day thousands
more are parked here for repairs and
refueling shanti devi and her husband
set up a tea shop here 20 years ago they
expanded the business to start a tire of
their workshop the shop is hard work the
to put in at least 10 hours every day
sometimes more the tires way at least 50
kilos and have to be moved around the
shop has no toilet and no electricity
connection if they were going on
beginning look that's an old tire it's
traveled thousands of kilometres through
slush and mud and God knows what else
you have to be prepared to get your
hands dirty it's a tough job hard work
is something the 55 year old is used to
she grew up in poverty in the central
Indian state of Madhya Pradesh working
all her life as a seamstress and in a
cigarette factory to make ends meet her
husband rhombohedral says he initially
had doubts about his wife working with
him in a trucking center but she's
proved her mettle this isn't a woman's
job it's a man's job but here who have a
woman who's turn a man's job of course
on a proud of her but her presence in an
environment heavily dominated by men
still raises eyebrows here now as a
board ruled ruled that one down I've
traveled a lot in my life and I've never
seen anything like this a woman working
as a truck mechanic and really amazed he
won't let it overcome name I don't think
this work is man you need a lot of
strength for this you have to change
tires pickin boots men are more
knowledgeable about but mohammed islam
who was hired as a mechanic Basanti
daily
Greece I have no problem working for a
run we work together as a team Shanti
and a husband make around 470 euros a
month they saved enough to build a house
which they share with the children and
the families though Shanti Devi herself
was unable to get school she's
determined that her granddaughter's get
a good education for any earlier people
used to say why educate a girl she's
going to get married anyway and will
stay at home but that's wrong it's
important for whom enough to stand on
her own feet so that she can feed
herself and her children have needed
Shanti Devi is now urging her
daughters-in-law to learn sewing and get
some part-time work she's very inspiring
you realize that women can do any job
and they're equal to men Shanti Devi
hopes her story will embolden other
women to break barriers